all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with secret Invasion
and in this video we are covering the
involvement of Deadpool now Deadpool is
going to prove to be probably the most
important person in the entirety of
secret invasions this is the reason why
we're covering the tie-ins plus it's
Deadpool it's a little weird because I'm
not sure everybody on my channel is a
fan of Deadpool but the thing about this
is that this basically picks up with the
Scrolls launching their invasion of
Earth now remember when it comes to
secret Invasion the campaign of the
Scrolls was launched in two fronts the
first one was basically duplicating
superheroes and then sending them to
Earth and sending the superhero
Community into a state of disarray
because you basically have like Iron Man
fighting Iron Man or Luke Cage fighting
Luke Cage and the superheroes themselves
are kind of asking each other are you a
scroll are you not a scroll and so it
creates distrust among the superhero
Community which is already fractured in
the aftermath of Civil War and so that
fracture begins to go even deeper the
other part of this was just a
traditional Invasion right aliens
arriving on Earth and just attacking
people and so that's really what kind of
goes on here they arrive at a baseball
game and of course you've got the mascot
kind of walking around doing mascot
stuff now the thing about this is it is
a Deadpool comic it's not going to be
serious it's going to be comedic just
the nature of things and so in fact when
they show up here they talk about the
nature of like the spirit of competition
that people have and so it's one of
those things where they're like it's
kind of ironic that this this race of
human beings that's trying to find some
measure of Peace constantly engages in
competitive attitudes which basically
have their entire bases in warlike
Tendencies so literally the human race
is leaning into its wartime or its
war-like mentality while trying to avoid
its warlike mentality at the same time
but the funny thing about this is they
basically have like this mascot right so
literally they analyze everybody here
and they're like okay so basically like
they're all humans except for that guy
now the Scrolls don't know what mascots
are they have no idea that it's
basically a human being running around
and side of an animal costume and trying
to trying to Hype up a crowd which
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't but once they Analyze This
mascot they realize that it's armed and
it's wearing body armor and outside of
basically any sporting event in the
south side of Chicago why in the world
would a mascot need to be armed and wear
body armor right like a Kevlar suit so
they end up firing on it and literally
like nothing happens but the mascot just
like like it looks like it's dead but it
looks like it's like like totally taken
out but then like it immediately pops up
and it's Deadpool with bullet holes and
everything and just opens fire on these
guys with Advanced Weaponry now the
funny thing here is at that point
they're like okay obviously this guy's
like some kind of an issue we got to
deal with this guy right we'll take him
out but they don't really see him as
being like overly important right and
that's one of the funny things is
Deadpool's usually one of those guys
where he's underestimated by people who
don't know who he is but the funny thing
is like as they're monitoring this whole
thing they're sending down troops right
so basically take care of what's you
know those individual people who are
there to take care of Deadpool but he's
just tearing them to pieces one because
of his advanced healing Factor right so
he can basically heal from pretty much
anything and two because of the fact
that the guys got just firearms and just
unloading everything on everyone now one
of the funny situations is when those
soldiers get down there Deadpool has
like the secondary voice in his head so
one of the things that's happened when
it came to Deadpool and Marvel Comics in
kind of a quick little history here is
you had Deadpool who was originally
introduced by Rob liefeld right so he
was like the super high octane
fast-paced superhero of like the 1990s
more of an anti-hero than anything else
but you didn't really know where his
Allegiance is lie he thought Wolverine
and cable for a little while that
bolstered his popularity because they
were so popular and then he started
dropping off in popularity because
people stopped buying comics in the late
1990s basically Joe Kelly started
writing Deadpool gave him more of like a
dark humor where he broke the fourth
wall a couple times Christopher priest
got his hands on Deadpool and he started
breaking the fourth wall all the time
and then Marvel started bringing in
things like additional voices inside of
his head to where he would basically
talk to himself and these different
voices have represented different
aspects of his character but that's why
you literally see him just conversing
with a voice in his own head because
it's kind of his moral compass to a
degree so it's almost like the narrator
explaining what's going on but the thing
about this is that as he's in this
situation and he's facing off against
these Scrolls as insane as it is he
basically starts seeing these Scrolls in
a way where they're like oh my God is
that Deadpool holy cow Deadpool we love
you man can we get your autograph and
that's when he's like I'm I'm
hallucinating again aren't I and the
voice in his head's like yeah basically
because like they're shooting at him and
so he just starts attacking all these
guys just starts pummeling them and so
because of the fact that he's just
demolishing all these scroll forces they
do the only thing they can do right
because at this point their Commander is
just kind of frustrated and he's fed up
right he's like okay this guy keeps
cracking jokes he's taken out our forces
like come on guys it's one man we're
like the the scroll Empire which is
achieved Interstellar travel we should
be able to take this guy out fairly
quickly but the problem with this is
like as they're attacking this guy like
as they're attacking Deadpool he's
crushing their forces and so they end up
firing on him using their ships like
weapon cannons right which basically
like annihilates the mascot body which
leads them to believe that like he's
been killed the problem is when they get
to the mascot he's not there like he's
gone and in fact he's on top of the ship
and so what they end up doing and
realizing that is they dispatch the
super scroll now the super scroll is
kind of the Scrolls sort of prime weapon
right technically speaking the super
scroll was basically a member of the
scroll race who had all the powers of
the Fantastic Four what goes on here in
secret invasion is that the super scroll
has kind of changed his purpose to where
it's basically a combination of
different superheroes Powers so really
it's not really the super scroll in the
traditional sense it's not a scroll that
has the powers of the Fantastic Four
it's just a super scroll that has a
variety of powers unto themselves right
so kind of borrowing that concept and
changing it up a little bit but what
ends up happening is with Deadpool
basically on this ship he starts
planting these bombs and then detonates
them and actually incapacitates the ship
destroys the scroll ship and so when
that happens the whole thing comes
crashing down onto super scroll and
basically takes him out and so with
everybody basically you know at least
the the idea of them being dead you have
Deadpool who rolls into the scene right
and it's like okay he finds the
commander of the scroll Army right that
guy's basically alive he finds the
commander he walks up on him and he's
like okay so here's the thing right he's
like tell me does your scroll medical
plan cover massive head wounds on
bullets of the dome right like two in
the dome piece and so this guy's like
whatever like you know if you expect me
to bag for my life that's not gonna
happen like I'm not gonna beg and plead
whatever do your worst and so Deadpool
goes to pull the trigger and it's a fake
gun right one of those little pop guns
it just says bang and the guy's like
what in the world is going on here right
and so of course the super scroll
reemerges he attacks Deadpool and so he
literally seizes him and he's like did
you really believe you could take on the
full might of the scroll Empire and
Deadpool's response is no no no you you
don't understand right like you're
misinterpreting everything right this is
all part of my plan now the reality is
this is not Deadpool's plan it's
somebody else's plan Deadpool's working
for another guy and it's one of the
coolest things because Deadpool's like
okay just so you guys know I'm not here
to attack you I was here to get your
attention I was here to show you you
need a guy like me on your side if your
entire secret Invasion event is gonna go
off without a hit so here's the deal
Wade Wilson reporting for Duty I'm here
to join your cause I'm here to help you
annihilate the entirety of the superhero
Community Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end I know
it's a short one thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace